now i have to admit lately whenever i
see your name attached to a film i'm
like i have to see it well that's not
green of it the one I love listen up
philip i am really into indie so when
you come to looking at something like
truth what was it that really intrigued
you about this story firstly robert
redford and cate blanchett of course i
probably would do anything they did like
spongebob movie idea man those are the
first two things and then the script is
beautiful it was so moving and
interesting and and well done would you
cite tells something Lajja a logic truth
about journalism it definitely does i
think it's it's important to know that
it is one person's story Mary Mapes and
you know so Kate's character but at the
same time of course it does you know
comment upon the larger world of
journalism today and the sort of death
of journalism and the change going into
the digital age and of course yeah
what's our next move I might have
something for the election the president
of the United States may have gone AWOL
from the military is journalism a hard
thing to show on screen people do it
really well like you know we've been
mentioning All the President's Men a lot
like you know it is something that is
kind of surprisingly done weld and when
you have a feeling about documents and
typefaces and you know somebody not
returning your call it's like that
doesn't necessarily sound super
suspenseful it's not like a you know cop
and robbers sort of drama but there is a
suspense to it we do manage to create
that of course people mention all the
President's Men also because truth stars
Robert Redford as well what was he like
when you're working with him on set oh I
couldn't get used to the fact that it
was Robert Redford I just never could
get used to and I just tried so hard to
have like a normal conversation with him
and just every time I just would like it
lost in the fact that i was talking to
Robert Redford I mean it's like
impossible to get over it he's the
nicest individual the only person who
might even be nicer is dan Rather like
the two of them are just two of the
nicest most gentlemanly like they do not
make them like them anymore I mean
they're just amazing thank you so much
Elizabeth moss from truth make sure you
see truth in cinemas and buy tickets on
fandango that's a violation light weight
you